Papá mamá, una pregunta complicada, dos opciones y una única respuesta. Hoy os voy
a plantear cuestiones muy variadas que nos han dejado los pizarritas en Instagram, en
arroba somos pizarritas. Arrancamos por ejemplo con una de la selección.
Vale, vale. Venga. Pregunta Mantú López. Como 9 de España,
Mikel Ollarzabal o Ferran Torres? Mikel Ollarzabal.
Mikel Ollarzabal. Ferran Torres.
Yo me quedo con Mikel por lo visto en la selección. Si no le estuviesemos viendo rindiendo tan
bien creo que sería unánime Ferran Torres. Sí, claro. Lógicamente.
Es que es lógico. No, lo que voy es que si de repente se lesionan
los dos delanteros y hay que ubicar a uno, creo que no había dudas con Ferran por su
nivel con el club. Pero rindiendo también Mikel con la selección…
Sí, ya que está funcionando tan bien, yo no lo tocaría de momento.
Así tú lo cambiarías ¿no? Sí, pensalo sobre todo en el Mundial. Creo
que… Es que Ferran… Esto lo decía mucho Luis Enrique cuando apostaba mucho por Morata
y lo terminaba cambiando. El trabajo de desgaste que te puede generar un delantero como Ferran
me parece valiosísimo. Creo que atrae muchas atenciones más que lo que puede atraer Ollarzabal.
Creo que además para esos tipos de partidos contra selecciones del mismo nivel que España
te saca un poquito a jugar más y que no se encierre tan atrás, creo que te puedes tirar
un poco mejor. A mí es un 9 que me gusta más que Ollarzabal.
¿Perdir la bala de Ferran desde el banquillo? Yo por eso prefiero a Mikel de titularia.
Es que yo creo que España tiene buenos revulsivos. En la lista suelen ir buenos revulsivos.
Sí. No lo tengo tan claro.
Bueno, yo creo que en una lista normal podemos ver a Baena, podemos ver a Jeremy, ya veremos
si hay un perfil para lanzar a la bolsa… Pero en la selección…
Sí, que verá que no han terminado de dar ese golpe como revulsivo.
Pueden ser bien en la teoría, pero el único recambio que ha funcionado desde el banquillo
ha sido Mikel Merino. Y no lo digo solo por el día de España, o sea, por el día de
Alemania, sino porque el resto se ha quedado a medio camino. Pero bueno, sí que es verdad
que pintan mejor en la teoría de lo que luego quizás son en la práctica.
Es que tampoco se ha necesitado mucho España, quiero decir.
Ya, bueno, es posible, pero no sé. A mí los cambios, por ejemplo, del día de la final
de la Nations ante Portugal se me quedaron muy cortitos.
Pues lete-bajo-llamas. Lete-bajo-llamas, supéralo now.
¿Prime de Banega o prime de Sergio Canales? Uf…
Sergio Canales. Para mí Banega.
Banega, Banega. Ha tenido influencia en copas del mundo también,
Banega. Para mí esos diferenciales…
A mí el PC más disfrutable es Sergio Canales. ¿Y qué copa del mundo ha tenido influencia?
Joder, la de 2018, el pase que le mete a Messi contra Nigeria.
Ah, que crea que es el de 2022. O sea, el pase que es, el pase que Messi controla y dirige
en el mismo paso, ¿no? A mí me parece un pase increíble.
Yo me quedo con Banega, pero al margen de la sección.
No pase. De hecho, para mí el desempeño de Banega
con la selección… Yo esperaba más.
Sí, claro. También hay que ver los entrenadores que tuvo la selección argentina hasta ese momento.
Sí. Que ahora mira la generación que tiene
de centros gampistas que son muy buenos, pero que han encontrado un técnico…
Igual le hubiera venido bien tener a Escaloni antes.
Claro. Básicamente.
Tercera cuestión.
Ah, el Arsenal de Ferguson. No, el United de Ferguson.
Sí. Sí.
¿Se romantiza demasiado el Arsenal de BenQ?
No, no. No, no.
Díselo. Díselo.
¿Cuántas Premier League…?
Hay unos cuantos turas como el del Llanó que…
No. ¿Cuántas Premier League?
¿Cuántas Premier League? No, no.
Es que si no me dejas terminar la frase… No.
¿Cuántas Premier League sin perder ningún partido ha ganado el Manchester United?
Ah, bueno. Bueno, bueno.
¿Cuántos equipos lo han hecho?
No sé. Está muy bien ganar.
El pató muchos partidos. Sí.
¿Tú qué prefieres? ¿Ganar 8-0 un día o ganar 8 días 1-0?
Claro. 8-0 un día.
Claro.
Si me da la oportunidad de ganar un día 8-0…
Raguántico. Yo creo que…
Es que no hay color.
Yo creo que lo que más pueden debatir es en iconografía.
Porque el Arsenal, a nivel icónico en ese sentido, sí que creo que competió con el
delante de Ferguson. A nivel competitivo…
Sobre todo de tiempo. De tiempo.
De títulos…
¿Por qué Ferguson ha ganado 13 Premiers?
No. ¿Pero cuántas las ha ganado Invicto?
Eh, eh. No, no. Zero.
Oye, ya está.
Tiene una copa dorada.
No, no. Alex Ferguson tiene 13 Premiers que a mí me daría vergüenza de ganar.
Y te diría… ¿Dónde entraron mejor los goles?
¿En la red de Highbury o en la de Old Trafford?
Buah, en la de Highbury.
Haybury que rebotaba ahí.
Está precioso Highbury ahora de lo que han hecho.
Se fueron del estadio también. Bueno, están al lado.
Están al lado. Fue poco la casilla de la Athletic Club.
Sí, que te bajas en la parada…
Te bajas en la parada de Metro Arsenal, vas a la izquierda, vas a Highbury, vas a la derecha, vas a la Envi.
Para unos apartamentos ahí… Pero que está chulísimo, eh.
Sí, sí, se ha dado. Lo han preservado de manera espectacular.
Lo han mantenido como… La portada.
Exactamente. Y ¿entraste al jardincito interior?
Sí. Y de hecho, en la entrada,
en el suelo está el escudo antiguo del Arsenal con el cañón, etcétera y tal.
Y está con el art deco original.
Sí. O también un poco chapas que tú estás viviendo ahí
y viene gente de Arsenal, ¿no?
Sí. O sea, es como si a tu urbanización de repente…
No, mira… Llega de repente…
Marcó un Goldberg Camp. Bueno, sí que…
Llega de repente… El Álex de Llano.
Señor, déjeme… Vamos, yo estuve ahí 20 minutos
vamos haciendo fotos y viendolo y tal.
Y llega Thierry Enri y dice, oye, ¿no hay partido hoy?
Y aquí… No se puede.
Me dijeron que ahí donde las urbanizaciones de Highbury
hay un recuerdo a las Champions que ganó el Arsenal de Venguero.
¡Oh!
Sí.
Mira, en el… En el mundo…
El portal. En el fútbol…
El fútbol tiene una cosa bellísima. Los clubes
que presumen de su grandeza a raíz de títulos
y los que la presumen a raíz de su estilo
y de su… Eso, eso.
Eso solo lo dice alguien que lo ha ganado.
Y de las cicatrices de las que ha sabido sanar.
Te digo el odio que… O sea, el cántico
¿qué más suena en el fútbol? Ser de los que ganan
es muy fácil o ser de…
Me parece mejor. Pues a mí me parece un cántico
que representa muchísimo el fútbol.
Sé que es un popular opinión.
Pero nadie se hace…
O él. 90%
de la gente se hace del equipo. No porque
ha ganado ese año concreto por el título.
Bueno, eso sí. A nivel extranjero sí.
Claro que sí. Y a nivel nacional.
Hay muchísimo subecarro, Miguel. A ti te mola el Arsenal de Venguero, ¿no?
A mí me mola el Arsenal de Venguero. Claro.
¿Cuándo te empezó a molar? Eh…
Justo antes de 2004. Te lo juro. Cuánto…
Sí, sí. ¡Sí, sí! ¡Sí, sí!
¡Sí, sí! ¡Sí, sí! ¡Sí, sí! ¡Sí, sí!
Lo primero que se ha hablado de la previa de Inmixtos es que…
Bueno, eh… Que, oye…
Que… Oye, mola ser de los equipos
pequeños, pero hay un debate
muy de aficionados, de club, que no está acostumbrado a ganar, que es
oye, qué bonito sería ser
del Madrid o del Barça, cuando ves a algún equipo
grande ganando y dices, oye, es que te complicaría
mucho menos la vida, sufriría mucho menos. Yo lo que te digo es que
sí, fuera… Luego te gusta lo que
te gusta. Tú, mirando
hacia afuera, fuera de tus fronteras,
normalmente eres del que gana un
torincúrico tras un equipo de NBA, yo qué sé, por Kobe
y Brian, por Michael Jordan, esto es normal. De hecho
me hacía mucha alegría que cuando Don Chik se fue a los Lakers
decían, bueno, ahora no sé de dónde
los Lakers. Claro, tú te hiciste cuando jugaba
Luke Walton, no te jodé. Claro, no.
Te gustaría Kobe, te gustaría Zack, te gustaría
quien sea. ¿O Chamberlain?
En el caso de Alex De Jarno. Yo he hecho una discusión que
he tenido mucho en casa, que
mis padres y mi hermano son muy del Barça por Ronaldinho.
No, pues es que es normal. Claro, pero
es que si Ronaldinho no hubiera ganado la Champions, ni hubiera
ganado un balón de oro, pues
no sería tampoco el día de hoy.
No, no, que sí, obviamente.
No solo eso. Pero lo que te veo es que la mayoría
termina siendo del equipo del que es su padre.
Igual su padre en su momento
se hizo por mi hermano o por su abuelo.
Suele ser más familiar.
En casa es una guerra civil. Hereditario.
No sé, es que lo de tirarle a la gente que es del Madrid, del Barça o del Atleti,
que no, es que te hiciste porque
ganaba. De verdad, me parece
un poco chorrada. Me parece
fácil. Sé que se han coapulado.
Más chorrada que hacerte el equipo por el estilo de juego.
No, no, no.
Antes de que lo tuvieras.
Yo tengo un colega que se hizo del Depor,
siendo de Valencia,
porque jugando al FIFA no sabía qué equipo
cogerse y el escudo que más bonito le parecía era
el del Depor. Razón del Depor de ir
a Riazor y todo. Muy legítima.
Razón muy legítima. Gabi PC3.
Cambiamos de temática.
Ya os he dicho que es variadito. A ver. Ruy de
galarreta o Luis Milla. Luis Milla.
Luis Milla. Yo me quedo con
Ruy de galarreta. Galaxy está bien, pero a mí me gusta más
con Luis Milla. O otro ritmo. Podrían jugar
los dos juntos. Sí, desde luego. Creo que hace más
cosas con Luis Milla. Luis Milla juega a otro ritmo,
pero el Ruy de galarreta tiene un desplazamiento
que no tiene Luis Milla. Bueno,
si la opinión. A balón parado
creo que tampoco hay discusión. Sí, no, no. A balón
para Luis Milla. Bueno, entonces el desplazamiento, ¿no?
Pero, bueno, sí, pero el Athletic Club
muchas veces echa falta al Ruy de galarreta. No me
refería con desplazamiento del toque de balón. Me refería
a la organización del juego. ¿Quién es el más imprescindible del
Centro del Campo de Athletic Club? Bueno, sí, claro.
Jaureguiza. A ver, es que si Jaureguiza
juega con Luis Milla. Claro. También sería Miquel
Jaureguiza. Bueno, pero...
Bueno, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Os hemos pillado. Os hemos pillado.
No, no, no. No engañéis a mi padre.
No, no, no. No, no, no.
No es el mejor. No, no, no. Joder,
¿cómo le cambió?
Joder, ¿cómo le cambió?
A ver, la verdad.
Bendecido. Pongo el tuit
de, ostras, Mario Machín para darle un poco de bola
al vídeo. Yo no quiero decir nada
al respecto. Quinta cuestión.
97JGC
es el
Instagramer que nos lo pregunta. Instagramer.
En cuanto a juego, y os pido que no seas
presentistas porque si no... Vale. Vale.
El Che de Sarabia. Claro,
el Che de Sarabia, la Brasil de 70.
La Brasil de 70 tenía Victor
Chuy y Afen Gruber en defensa. Estaban cebas.
Claro, no. Pero dice
el Che de Sarabia o Las Palmas de Pimienta.
Vamos a quedarnos con
la primera vuelta de Las Palmas de Pimienta
que es la que se puede comparar con la segunda
de color. El Che de Sarabia.
En términos de nivel o de divertimiento?
Porque el divertimiento, compro el Che...
Creo que no hay discusión.
Y luego en términos de nivel, es cierto
que tiene un tramo de final de año,
en noviembre y diciembre, que empieza a jugar
un poquito mejor, que empieza a calgurar,
que regresa a moleiro, que empieza a lesionar la temporada.
Que, oye,
que mucho mejor. Que es cuando
los goles de fuera del aire a Kirian.
Yo creo que fue el mejor momento de las
Palmas de Pimienta. Y aún así te quedas con el Che.
Y aún así me quedo con el Che. Para mí tenía más mérito lo de Las Palmas
porque creo que encontrar a alguien que
marcaron goles en ese equipo era verdaderamente complicado.
De hecho, Kirian creo que era pitxite, precisamente,
con esos tres goles de fuera del área.
A mí me parecen dos equipos parecidos.
Creo que aquel año deportivo a Las
Palmas agradecería tener una pareja de delanteros con la que tiene
el Che. Y al Che le sentaría muy bien
Kirian. Creo que un centro campista como Kirian
le sentaría muy bien al Che de Sarabia.
Y vaya portería tenía aquel año a Las Palmas,
porque tenía a Arón Escandéi de suplente.
Y Álvaro Valles de titular.
No juego Brasil en el 82.
Sé que has dicho Brasil de 70.
Pero me he dado Brasil del 82 a ver si jugó
en el Martínez Valero.
A ver si jugó a Feng Gruber.
No sabía por dónde estaba yendo.
A ver si se nos ha escapado.
No es el caso.
No juego en el Martínez Valero.
En Sánchez, Tijuana, Merito Villamarín y Sarria.
¿Me tangaron a la Ursa ahí?
Por eso se desplomo.
Me llaman Riz.
En La Liga.
En el bar.
Es en el FICO.
Es Jhon Arne.
En La Liga.
Intélige.
Manuel Pellegrini.
O Ernesto Valverde.
Me parece muy complicado.
Papá a mamá.
Dos de los grandes entrenadores.
Cantidad de partidos sin gente.
No sé quién lleva más.
Yo me quedaría con Valverde.
Ha ganado más títulos.
Más clasificaciones a Champions.
Más títulos.
Pellegrini entraba en Madrid.
Cristiano Ronaldo...
Valverde casi ha sido una Liga Invicto.
Le hemos dado un mérito tremendo.
No puedo con eso.
Se quedó la historia.
¿Quién fue el delantero?
Boateng.
Boateng impidió al Barça.
El Barça ganó el sextete.
Cambió la historia.
Sin ser ninguno de los dos...
Los tíos más carimáticos de la historia del fútbol.
Creo que Valverde tiene un poquito más que Pellegrini.
Ya que a méritos deportivos.
Creo que...
Son las dos entrevistas que más llevamos peleando.
Cinco años.
Y mira que hemos tirado hijos.
Amigos.
Pero no...
Cuando ellos quieran.
A Pellegrini últimamente le veo con ganas de hablar de la renovación.
Podemos llamar a la nueva puerta.
Monográfico renovación.
Le gustaría.
Yo...
¿Habéis dicho que estés Valverde?
Solo en Liga.
Yo Valverde.
Es que factor Champions a Valverde le podría salir.
Pero le hubo Balaga también.
Bueno, es que...
Ah, claro.
Pero City...
Puedes contar Malaga y Villarreal en Liga.
Que son finales y cuartos.
De hecho, curiosamente, con el equipo que llegó más...
Menos lejos fue con el Madrid.
Que cae en octavos de final.
O León.
La tenía que haber pasado a Iguayna Cristiano.
Eso vale para muchos partidos.
Cinco, seis años seguidos.
¿Quién es el que marca Pjanic en la vuelta?
¿Y en la ida qué marca?
Marca también un golazo desde fuera del área.
Un chaval.
¿Que un niño?
No, porque era de tez oscura.
A mí me encantaba...
Ya que hemos hablado del FIFA antes.
Me encantaba elegirme a ser Olympic de León en el FIFA.
Moraba mucho.
Ya misheola.
Yo me voy a quedar a Manuel Pellegrini
por no dar el pleno.
Juanjo Plos.
Estaba pensando...
¿Pellegrini ha ganado alguna Liga?
¿Pellegrini ha ganado Liga inglesa?
Sí, en inglés, español...
Ha ganado la Copa del Rey con el Betis.
Y Valverde sí que es dos veces campeón de Liga.
Sí, sí.
Y le destituyen yendo líder.
Con el Atleti Club.
Pero no ha ganado la Liga invicto.
Juanjo Plos.
¿Harry Kane o Juliano Álvarez?
¿Harry Kane?
Me da un poco de pereza.
Me da un poco de pereza Harry Kane.
Hago esta pregunta porque venimos del derbi.
Harry Kane quizás es el jugador más en forma del fútbol europeo.
Si hicimos un ranking del balón de oro,
quizás Harry Kane sería el número uno.
Ahora mismo en Mundo es Liga son 10 goles y 3 asistencias de 5 partidos.
Lojura.
A mí me encanta Julián, pero creo que Harry Kane.
Es que, además,
me parece que el tipo...
O sea, en Inglaterra ha marcado muchísimos goles en Premier.
Es muy bueno.
Es una manera de tener una continuidad
dentro de su carrera impresionante.
Te da pereza la gente hablando de Harry Kane,
pero Harry Kane no te puede dar pereza.
¿Por qué te da pereza Harry Kane?
Es que, ponle un mote a Harry Kane.
No puedes.
No puedes. No puedes.
Alex puede.
Dale.
O el bastón, porque Kane es bastón en inglés.
Me parece más completo Harry Kane.
Dicho lo cual...
O sea, objetivamente, el mejor jugador
no pasa nada.
Pero estamos aquí en plan...
Sí, si puede. Vale el gusto.
¿Quién te transmite más cosas?
Julián. Julián.
¿Tú más que te des Harry Kane?
Harry Kane, que encima es el 9 del Bayern.
Hombre, pues sí.
Va a meter un carro de goles.
Pero se va a meter también en el Tottenham.
Claro.
Oye, se podrían dar la mano...
Se podrían dar la mano el Arsenal y el Tottenham
y se podrían marchar de este mundo.
¿Qué te pasa?
Nadie notaría que...
¿Qué le pasa a este hombre hoy?
Los equipos de Londres en general,
salvo el Crystal Palace...
Claro, porque el Arsenal es el mejor equipo del mundo.
¡Vamos!
Saúl 4.
La comparativa, menos comparable.
Son los jugadores...
Si me dicen dos jugadores muy diferentes
entre sí. Un huevo y una castaña.
El huevo podría ser
Cuaresma.
Y la castaña, Hulk.
Vale.
Tienen buen lanzamiento desde lejos.
Sí, pero hasta uno con el exterior
y el otro con el feine.
Yo con Hulk.
Es la comparación esa.
Yo Cuaresma, la magia.
Hulk.
A rasar.
Le vi en directo a sus 39 años
en Atlético Mineiro.
En Maracaná.
El Atlético Mineiro no da pereza.
La verdad es que el partido fue horrible.
¡Gol de uva!
¿Cómo?
Vamos a cambiar un término.
Yo soy muy mal hablado, voy a no hablar mal.
El 29 de septiembre te has perdido
la frase que citaba una editorial.
Ya me ha llegado.
Cuando tú la ligas, a mí me mandan mensajes.
Citando al genio de Moaña.
Como si yo tuviera poder de influencia sobre ti.
Disfrutando siendo el cartero.
¿Gol de uva? Joderle el ascenso.
Al final lo he dicho.
Fastidiarle.
Fastidiarle el ascenso a tu máximo rival
o hacerlo descender.
Hacerlo descender.
Sí.
Es que la alegría...
La alegría.
La alegría de subir
no compensa el dolor de bajar.
Sí.
No habría que...
Igual hay casos concretos.
Ahora ha subido el Real Oviedo.
La gran alegría del Real Oviedo
es superior a la tristeza que sintió
en su día descendiendo.
Igual el descenso a categorías más bajas
que la segunda división dolió
mucho más.
Bajarlo te llena más.
Y no dejarle subir.
Sois dos ratas peleando por un churro.
Sí.
Con música de Linkin Park.
Sobre laterales derechos.
Yo suposti.
Kunde o Dani Carvajal.
Carvajal.
Yo me quedo con Carvajal.
Ahora mismo sería Kunde.
Carvajal de hecho está lesionado.
Carvajal tuvo sus momentos
un poquito variables.
No hay con los problemas físicos.
También te digo que Kunde
desde que es lateral derecho...
La última temporada.
La última temporada es el segundo
por detrás de Arrazo.
Le está pasando, por cierto,
en el Sport de Portugal a Maxi Araujo
un Kunde que lo están poniendo mucho
de cara a la izquierda, incluso de lateral.
No le gusta.
Siendo el extremo.
Pero está jugando bien.
Me he quedado pensando
en cuántos laterales derechos tiene Uruguay.
Pues la verdad es que vamos costos.
Araujo, Fede Valverde...
La realidad es que vamos costos.
Está Damian.
Uruguay está por encima de Damian Suárez.
Bueno, ha estado incluso en el PIC.
La verdad es que a Damian siempre el pobre.
Adán Contilde.
Ah, este es muy majo.
En cuanto a nivel, proyección y carisma
mete todo en la misma coctelera.
Puedes repetirlo.
Todo el nivel, proyección y carisma.
Etta John o Tierno Barrie.
Etta John.
Es que Etta John es un descubrimiento.
Pero en carisma gana Tierno Barrie.
Pero no por mucho.
Porque Etta John es muy bueno.
En carisma.
Ya he hablado de este vídeo.
Pero os invito a que veáis
la novatada que le gastan en el día real a Etta John
que lo ponen a cantar.
Oye, caminando por la vida
cantado por Etta John es mejor que
no.
Pero Tierno Barrie, estrimer, cuidado.
Si, Tierno Barrie
retando a los tuiteros.
Tirando vip.
Cuando el Villarras estaba jugando la quinta plaza
con el Betis, en la jornada
entre semana, y marcan un gol al Betis
le salta la notificación en el móvil y dice
Betis, bye.
Un poquito...
Sí, está bien.
Pero Etta John mola mucho.
Mejor que no lo vea Leberton.
No, Tierno Barrie, sino que se vea Tani.
Se pinta bien, pero hombre.
Cuidado, eh.
Nil Auko.
Coque o Tiago Alcántara.
Coque.
Tiago.
Pique.
Yo estoy de acuerdo ahí.
También no quería comparar un poco de Hulk y Cuaresma.
Porque en términos de vistosidad...
Coque es lo opuesto.
Coque es eficacia.
Y Tiago...
Me sabe muy mal, porque se habla
del mal que le ha hecho a la imagen de Coque
la selección, pero me sabe mal
que cuando hablas de la prórroga de Tiago
todo el mundo sabe de lo que estás hablando.
Y que la gente se haya quedado con esa imagen
y con que no haya terminado de calar en el Liverpool.
Pero es un jugador tan bueno.
Y en el Liverpool tiene momentos buenos.
El gol que le marca a Kroos al Brujas.
Para mí la temporada...
¿Es Conflict?
La temporada Conflict es mejor que el mejor
año de Coque. Pero creo que la carrera de Coque es superior.
Sí, sí. Aquel de Tiago, la barbá, el de Barça.
El gol de Chile, el de Stuttgart.
Javier Vidal.
Javier no.
Javier.
Tiene varias vocales.
¿Cómo? ¿Qué?
A ver, di.
Javier... Esta huida de adelante es bastante interesante.
Javier. Tiene dos es.
Por favor, por favor.
Quiero que os calléis todos y que hable solo Miguel Quintana.
Tiene dos es y dos is.
Javier Vidal.
Tiene dos is.
¿Es un Nick? Vidal.
Vidal. ¿Michael Jaureguizar o Pablo Barrios?
¿Sabes que la gente hace estas cosas?
Sobre todo porque no se ha podido poner Javier Vidal.
Yo intenté pillar
arrobaNawel y estaba pillado.
Y en la video decía soyNawel
y mi arroba no se lo doy a nadie.
Muy bien. Y luego publicaban a los que le intentaban hackear.
¿Jaureguizar o Barrios?
Barrios. Barrios.
Jaureguizar. Jaure.
Javier Galvin.
¿Cómo? Tiene varias is.
Rendir solo bien con tu selección.
Vamos a llamarlo Podolski.
Vale. Vale.
O rendir bien en tu equipo pero nunca con la selección.
Fede Valverde.
Jajajaja.
¿Qué preferís?
Mmm...
Uf. Podolski.
Depende. Todos los días del año. Depende la selección.
Claro. Imagínate.
Es Slovakia. Claro.
Y eres el de San Marino. Yo prefiero el club.
Yo creo que el club te va a comer.
Son muchos años.
Sí. Son muchos años.
Yo creo que también.
Es que hay tantos ejemplos buenos de jugadores de selección
que ponen una barbaridad.
Entre los... Ener Valencia,
Paolo Guerrero. Sí. Los Paolos también aquí
se infravalora. Porque
por ejemplo, Paolo Guerrero o Podolski
no rendían mal. Simplemente no rendían tan, tan, tan bien
como luego la selección.
En Colonia Podolski tiene grandes
temporadas. Para que en Alemania
es que daban bastante. Bien, el Arsenal tuvo un rol muy
interesante de suplente.
El Arsenal de... No. Sí, sí, sí.
El de los Invencibles. Mismo.
Mira, esta me ha gustado mucho. La historia se cuenta,
¿vale?
Gol de falta de Messi al Liverpool.
Uno de los goles más bonitos a nivel frontal.
Además, un gol como de falta canónico.
Si tú piensas en un gol de falta,
piensas ese. Ahora que me he cerrado del gol,
he hecho de menos ver fútbol en el Camp Nou.
Mmm... Ahora con
todo este baile... Los socios también.
Lo pensaba el otro día con todo este baile de estadios y tal.
Es raro. Es raro.
¿Vas a comparar goles de falta? Sí.
Insuperable. No lo compales.
Espérate. El de Messi.
Pues yo te digo uno mejor. El de Roberto Carlos Contragil.
A Francia.
Un gran torneo de verano. Es un valor.
Claro que es insuperable. No, no. Hay dos
momentos en el fútbol de selecciones
sobrevalorados.
Uno es ese gol
y otro es el escorpión.
Eso no fue...
Una jugada invalidada.
Es otra cosa. No era ni partido ni nada.
Pero esto...
Es verdad que luego el gol de Messi no sirve
para demasiado. ¿Sabes lo que pasa?
Bueno, es la idea de las semifinales.
A ver, por momentos...
Si se lo hubiese pasado de embele. Escucha,
pero si buscamos por momento trascendentes,
seguro que se nos ocurre un gol de falta más importante
que ese. Estaba pensando... En una final.
Pero se os ocurre un golazo de falta
en una final de un mundial. Porque a mí no se me viene
mucho a la cabeza.
Carlos, Alberto no marcó uno.
Con Brasil.
Pero es uno que llega desde atrás y creo que son cuartos.
¿Y una final de Champions? México 70.
Final de Champions.
Tampoco, ¿no? Tampoco.
Tampoco me viene a la mente. Seguro que hay.
De hecho, voy a ver el chat de YouTube a ver si
algún pizarrita nos ayuda.
Pero a mí, hombre, el de...
El de Roberto Carlos es que es...
A lo que voy... El otro es la perfección.
El de Roberto Carlos... Pero es que no existe.
No existe. Pero es que el de Messi, ¿dónde la pone?
Que sí, que sí, que sí.
Y la perfección echa falta.
El de Roberto Carlos no existe.
El escenario hace mucho. Sí, sí, sí.
Preguntas ahí a los 15 minutos de ese gol de falta.
Alguno de Liverpool si quería ir a remontar
y te dice... Bueno, los llevo el otro día.
Claro, le dicen el gol de Koeman, evidentemente,
porque estamos pensando en Champions más reciente.
Sí, más reciente.
Es espectacular e histórico,
pero tampoco es el gol de falta
más bonito del mundo.
Bueno, pero dice... ¡Uf!
Le ha pegado como si le debiera dinero.
Luis Alagunés de falta al Bayern.
Ah, cierto. Pero vamos, nos está quedando...
Un poco lejano. Estamos pensando
en reciente. Reciente.
Y no se me ocurre. Hicimos 20 años.
Alguno habrá, eh. Amigos futbolistas,
ponedlo en las pilas. Hay que tirar mejor
las faltas. Sí, sí.
Este 2026 hay que... Mira, este es muy bueno,
es verdad. Me lo pasa
Sergio. El de Bekan
contra Grecia en la Euro,
el minuto 93 para clasificarse.
No, no, no. Es clasificación para el
Mundial. Último minuto. Bekan supercriticado.
Que salen el... Sí, sí.
Salen el documental. Sí, muy bueno.
Exactamente. Que es después de...
Y luego le marca
Ronaldinho a Schimann.
Y ya dos para finalizar.
Venga. Mario Cabello.
El resurgir de Péremilla o el de Rafa Mir?
Rafa Mir.
Pérez. Yo no me lo esperaba.
Y José Medina.
Ah. Creo que era la última.
He hecho dos para acabar.
Te hago la de
Chuty con Blon y los patrones.
Mira, luego el tiempo que
perdemos en eso y no en hablar de las premias.
Papá o mamá, ¿vale?
O suegra
o cuñado. Suegra o cuñado.
Suegra o cuñado. Es que mola ser
faltoso. Papá o mamá.
No, no.